[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
habe heute wieder ein richtig cooles
rezept für euch und zwar steht jetzt in
wester bevor
und ich habe mir gesagt mensch was mache
ich denn da zum essen wir bekommen ein
bisschen besuch und natürlich habe ich
keine lust am stundenlang in der küche
zu stehen
also kommt dieses chili con carne wie
gerufen denn ich kann es gut vorbereiten
kann es auch am tag vorher schon zu
bereiten das ist auf jeden fall ein
kraut väter also man bekommt wirklich
ganz ganz viele menschen damit satt und
es ist einfach super lecker
ich zeige es euch machen hier habe ich
das chili con carne und ursprünglich
sagt man kommt dieses rezept aus texas
oder arizona man weiß es nicht ganz
genau und die ursprünge sind auch sehr
sehr sehr umstritten
das einzige wo man sich wirklich einig
ist sind zwei zutaten und zwar chili und
fleisch daher auch der name chili con
carne chili mit fleisch und ansonsten
ist die zubereitung glaube ich einfach
jedem selbst überlassen
es gibt nicht wirklich das
originalrezept das macht das chili
einfach so wie es euch am besten
schmeckt und heute gibt's hier meine
variante also verließ chili das sieht
hier schon mal richtig lecker aus ich
habe hier das hackfleisch vom rind
schreibt die kidney bohnen und den mais
was für mich wirklich typisch texmex ist
und dazu gibt's bei mir selbst gemachtes
baguette und zwar ist es das magische
agiert ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal
ganz kurz welche zutaten ihr benötigt
diese menge reicht jetzt sag ich mal für
ungefähr sechs bis acht personen
4 2 für dich und mich je nachdem wie
groß natürlich der hunger ist aber ich
würde mal sagen wenn sie jetzt nur chili
con carne gibt mit baguette sag ich mal
zu sechs bis acht personen
die vorne sind die zutaten für das
original sally chili con carne benötigen
wir olivenöl zwiebeln getrocknete
tomaten kidney bohnen und mais aus der
dose vanille extrakt tomaten aus der
dose hier habe ich einen espresso
schwarzer herren schokolade verschiedene
chili sorten salz und pfeffer ich hab'
ich cayennepfeffer oregano
und etwas zimt und kreuzkümmel natürlich
auch knoblauchzehen und rindfleisch ich
starte jetzt zuerst mit dem rindfleisch
da habe ich jetzt ein kilo rind und zwar
ist der inder hals und ich mach das
hackfleisch immer gerne selber so weiß
ich einfach dass die qualität wirklich
super ist und ich kann das fleisch auch
selber bestimmen und natürlich auch den
fettgehalt und das werde ich jetzt
einfach kurz durch den fleischwolf jagen
[Musik]
das fleisch ist fertig ich habe schon
etwas olivenöl in meinen großen topf
gegeben und ich nehme mir jetzt einen
gusseisernen topf damit ich den später
einfach auch in den backofen schieben
kann
und das fleisch wird in mehreren
portionen angebraten und die
zwischenzeit habe ich auch genutzt und
die tomaten schon eingeweicht die
getrockneten denn ihr könnt sie entweder
ganz getrocknete tomaten nehmen die
müssen mit heißem wasser eingeweicht
werden so wie bei mir oder ihr nehmt die
dann bereits in öl aufgeweicht sind da
müsste dann nichts mehr einreisen
[Musik]
jetzt hab ich's komplette hackfleisch
angebraten und gebe jetzt das restliche
olivenöl in den topf und kann jetzt auch
die zwiebeln und den knoblauch würfel
anbraten
die habe ich nämlich bereits mit dem
scharfen alle klein geschnitten dass
charlie der alligator da freut sich mein
bruder
während die zwiebeln angebraten werden
kümmere ich mich schon mal um die chili
schoten die hatte ich noch vom sommer
übrig und hat das sich im tiefkühlfach
gelagert und zum schneiden verwende ich
einweg handschuhe damit ich die schafe
nicht an den händen habe
[Musik]
die getrockneten tomaten habe ich
abgegossen und das wasser aufgefangen
und die werden jetzt in einem mixer fein
zerkleinert
[Musik]
die chilischoten gebe ich jetzt hier mit
zu den zwiebeln
da musst du echt aufpassen habe ich
alles nicht so schlimm oder
da kommt gleich der espresso das so und
wer möchte kann hier statt espresso auch
rotwein oder zum weiteren dunkles bier
verwenden oder natürlich auch
fleischbrühe gebe ich kleider die
tomaten drauf damit dass chili mir nicht
inhalt und hals so weiter aufsteigt
weil reden und chili anbraten sind so
zwei dinge die nicht gleichzeitig
funktionieren
ich spreche aus erfahrung da kommt jetzt
mal auf die passt damit rein von den
tomaten die sorgen natürlich auch für
einen kräftigen geschmack und für eine
kräftige farbe
[Musik]
hier kommt jetzt natürlich auch das
hackfleisch wieder dazu und dann kommen
noch die gewürze rein und wenn ihr merkt
ihr habt zu wenig flüssigkeit könnt ihr
ein bisschen was vom tomaten wasser
dazugeben und jetzt auch sparsam mit dem
salz arbeiten denn die getrockneten
tomaten sind meist schon ein bisschen
gesalzen
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt das ci spezial sind es
schon drin also für lille extrakt
[Musik]
jetzt auch gerne mit pfeffer abschmecken
jetzt weiß ich dass chili einkochen und
zwar könne das ist entweder auf dem herd
machen bei niedriger stufe müsst aber ab
und zu hören oder gibt es einfach in den
backofen da stelle ich sitze nämlich
rein da kann unten nämlich nichts
anbrennen
natürlich muss ich trotzdem
kontrollieren und lass es jetzt einfach
für zwei bis drei stunden schmoren
das ist auch wirklich super wichtig der
geschmack entfaltet sich und ganz zum
schluss gebe ich dann noch den mais de
kidney bohnen und die schokolade dazu
[Musik]
ja und die zeit nutze ich jetzt um ein
baguette musik herzustellen sind paket
passt da wirklich perfekt dazu und das
rezept findet ihr bereits auf einem
kanal main market ist habe ich jetzt
hier rechts im backofen und praxis oft
mit dampf stoß dadurch jetzt nämlich
noch ein bisschen knuspriger und jetzt
kann man das chili fertigstellen
das habe ich jetzt hier links
reingeschoben jetzt wirklich hier noch
die restlichen zutaten dazu also die
kidney bohnen den mais
ein bisschen wasser lockt also ein
bisschen von der tomaten flüssigkeit und
zu guter letzt die gute herren
schokolade
jetzt kann ich die zutaten noch gut
durchmischen dann darf es gern noch mal
eine halbe stunde weiter köcheln und
dann können wir gleich sein werden
[Musik]
starten wir mit dem leckeren knusprige
baguettes das ist einfach immer perfekt
man muss den teig wirklich nur kurz mit
denn mit dem löffel verrühren und der
rest macht schon der backofen
ok ich glaube echte männer reisen ist
oder einfach oder so gut aber darum
kümmern wir jetzt gleich jetzt richtig
dass chili con carne die schälchen ja
keine sorge ich keine vorspeise schütze
auf den fotos schöneres schälchen aber
ihr kriegt gleich
er hat zum tippen ehekrieg gleich
richtige schälchen ok richtige tiefe
männer schauen
das ist so wahrscheinlich erst mal zehn
minuten warten bis es ein bisschen
abkühlt ich finds ja perfekt wenn man
dazu etwas sauerrahm anrichtet einfach
so als klicks obendrauf viele verwenden
hier noch chatter käse oder auch
zwiebeln also da müsste wirklich so
servieren wie ihr das gerne möchte und
ich es dann einfach am liebsten wirklich
brot dazu dass bissle berühren und dann
essen aber ich will mir jetzt nicht
verbrauchen
alles ist okay ich warte ganz kurz zu
warten
[Musik]
das perfekte chili con carne wirklich
probiert auf jeden fall mal aus wenn ihr
silvester zubereitet dann markiert mich
auf instagram oder auf facebook ich
schaue auf jeden fall rein
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen wünsche euch alles alles gute
auch fürs neue jahr dauert zwar noch
bezahlt und wir sehen uns auch noch mal
aber das rezept findet ihr schon mal auf
salehs - blog.de ich wünsche euch viel
spaß dabei einen guten appetit und uns
auch an und jetzt im guten appetit bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]